h đấu nhầm nhầm
Ờ đợi tôi một
sẻ tâm sự nhiều phết mà mấy hôm nay kiểu
bị vướng khá nhiều thứ hôm trước kiểu
livestream còn bị mất mạng
nữa nên là kiểu nó cứ bị dồn ấy Ờ gì
nhỉ Ừ chắc là tôi để link đấy để để cho
mấy ông có thể xem trước là tôi sẽ định
nói gì hôm nay tôi định thêm cái cái
video này chẳng hạn Ờ Còn bây giờ trước
mắt thì Tôi nghĩ là tôi vẫn sẽ kiểu dạy
code trước đã xong rồi mới ngọn nhà sau
đó thì cuối buổi mình sẽ tâm sự mỏng sau
nha mỏng hoặc dày không biết được
Ờ thì hôm trước tôi có nói là thực ra là
cái tôi bởi vì mạy vẫn là dự án cá nhân
nên thành ra là kiểu và Lã cả
Ừ nó cũng là thói quen theo kiểu Tôi làm
hẳn xong tính năng hoặc là cần phải đổi
máy để tôi mới ới comit code lên nhưng
mà chuẩn chuẩn mấy ông đó là là mấy ông
luôn kiểu code xong gần như là kiểu code
code không phải xong dùng từ nhà nói
chung
là thường Nếu có thể thì thường comit
lên liên tục kiểu thế kiểu code hết ngày
hôm nay thì
comit code của ngày hôm nay đừng để hôm
sau
comit thậm chí là kiểu code mỗi buổi
sáng thì comit lên trước xong rồi có thể
là kiểu thường là thêm kiểu w p để HM
chỉ là kiểu
đang đang process chẳng hạn hay cái gì
gì đó Vân
Vân Nói chung là commit lên để tránh bị
mất code đấy Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là là
chính bản thân mình còn nhớ được là lúc
đấy lý do mình code cái đoạn đấy là gì
đấy nó là như thế đương nhiên là cá với
cá nhân tôi thì tôi vẫn nhớ được Lý do
tôi đã code đoạn đấy tôi thường hay tự
tin thế đó là thậm chí tôi có thể tự tin
mấy ông là tôi có thể mở cái code những
cái code đời đầu của tôi tôi từng khoe
mấy ông cái đấy rồi Hay là thử kiểm
chứng không nhỉ code đời đầu của tôi là
dùng trên github tôi code mấy cái k kiểu
tiện x tiện x Facebook
ấy
trước vừa rồi thấy rồi đây 7 năm trước
Xóa tất cả thành viên nhóm thực ra mấy
cái này quá đơn giản mấy ông thấy
không Trông rất là đơn giản có bốn mấy
dòng mà có ông nào đó bán cái đi các thứ
thứ kiểu chục triệu Có code này chỉ chạy
mấy cái kiểu như này đây cái cái này đ
đầu tiên thì thực ra để mà Giải thích
từng dòng thì bây giờ khá là dễ rồi để
mà Lý Do hồi đấy thì tôi thường hay
chuộng về vòng lặp do w về w hơn forx
thì bản chất là đúng là mình không biết
được lúc nà điểm dừng đấy
Ờ đây là link r để mà để mà kiểu gọi đến
api Facebook
lấy tất cả thành viên về sau đó thực à
là lấy mỗi trường ID của tất cả thành
viên về đấy Sau đó thì mình sẽ kiểu cul
à các thứ cái đoạn này tôi không hề hiểu
đoạn đấy Hồi này lắm copy về đấy
đầu tiên lấy tất cả thành viên về thì
lấy tất cả ID đúng không
admin thì thì à nếu nằm trong thì bỏ qua
Hồi đấy có chuyện là tự xỏa t thoát mình
khỏi nhóm
có nghe rất là Ui quả này cũng quả bấc
các thứ các thứ nên phải thêm quả Điền
ID ban quả trị không thì bay nói chung
hồi đấy làm khá sơ xài không bảo mật lắm
không quả này ai mà không để ý coi như
là tự kích mình khỏi nhóm
À đấy meod delete xóa này các thứ
thứ xong rồi mình để chặn không cho
Facebook kiểu đánh dấu spam thì 5 giây
mình chạy một lần xóa từng người từng
người 5 giây một lần Thế 5 giây hơi lâu
nhưng mà chạy nhưng mà nói chung là nó
chắc ấy Bạn cắm máy kể cầy thì kiểu dạng
là 5 giây một người thì ví dụ là 5000 à
1000 thành viên sẽ là 5 5000 giây
là 10.000 thành viên 100.000 thành
viên 100.000 thành viên chia cho 8 6 40
a 86 mất 5 ngày chạy 5 ngày để xóa
100.000 thành viên
Ừ cũng khp đến nỗi còn hơn mà chạy bằng
tay hoặc là bị chặn tính năng nhưng mà
nhưng mà kiểu bởi vì cứ 5 giây một lần
này nó cũng hơi gọi nh Facebook nó vẫn
quét các thứ thứ Nên là nói chung là
cũng bị giới hạn khá nhiều còn không thì
ông phải chơi bằng ra scrip để cho nó
kiểu bởi vì nó biết được gọi qua api này
rồi không tốt nên là ông có thể chạy
bằng ra scp để nó tưởng người thật đấy
là một
cách nói chung là mình không hề biết
được cơ chế hoạt động của Facebook thế
nào nên mình chỉ đoán một cách tương đối
như thế đấy code 7 năm trước thôi vẫn
hiểu mà thực ra cái đ này khá là dễ hiểu
không có gì cả Tôi không biết được có
đoạn nào phức tạp hơn để giải thích
Không nhưng mà tôi tự tin tôi tự tin là
ví dụ Giả sử là bây giờ công ty mới của
tôi có động vào cả code cũ của tôi hồi
đầu tôi mới vào là tận 2021 nhưng mà tôi
vẫn giải thích được Lý do tại sao tôi
code đạn đấy nó bình thường cả và thực
ra là
ơ tôi tưởng tắt rồi mình nh
ờ và thực ra là sếp tôi thường hay nói
đó là có nhiều lúc thì tôi đúng là tôi
kiểu dạng dạng nhở tôi kiểu à Ừ vẫn có
cái kiểu Chắc là có tính chá Con à không
phải chế con nữa Nói chung là sự non ấy
chắc là dùng sự sự non là kiểu Khi mà
mình kiểu chê codt người đi trước kiểu
code người đi trước tệ kinh khủng mình
nhìn vào đôi khi mình MU muốn đập đi làm
lại đấy nhưng mà sếp tôi thì bảo là em
đừng có chê đấy em có thể bảo đống đấy
là đống giác nhưng mà Ờ khi mà em đập đi
làm lại thì em chỉ biến mớ giác này
thành mớ giác khác thôi tức là sao Em
chỉ là người khác cũng thể nhìn vào code
mình cũng bảo đấy là mớ giác được mà Bởi
vì mình viết code thì bản chất là mình
vẫn là người hiểu nhất đấy là trong
trường hợp mà ông còn hiểu được ông C gì
nhá Có nhiều ông chẳng hiểu chẳng thể
giải thích được Tại tại sao mới cố đoạn
đấy cơ Thế thì lại tệ quá đấy nhưng mà
sếp tôi thường anh nói là kiểu là chắc
chắn là có lý do nào đó mà họ codt như
thế ví dụ thế rất nhiều cái à nên là
mình cũng phải xếp tôi thì luôn cố đọc
rất kỹ và cố đoán xem là lý do tại sao
người ta COD như thế này bởi vì sao Bởi
vì làm lâu rồi ấ thì ông sẽ hiểu là có
rất nhiều đoạn ông nhìn thấy kiểu đoạn
code ôi trông vô lý kinh khủng các thứ
các thứ
hiểu ấy chính tôi cũng thường hay bị
codt kiểu như thế đúng thế nên là anh em
trong công ty của tôi gần đây tôi khi mà
sang công sang dự án mới thì anh em vào
cái dự án cũ thì anh em còn bảo tôi
code kêu tôi là kiểu code của giáo sư
long à k đậu tức cả làm ch kiểu mình
code Đôi khi mình cũng nghĩ quá nhiều về
việc tối ưu nên thành ra là code trông
nó đọc nó khá là phức tạp Tôi sẽ không
thự nhận mình là clean code cho lắm bởi
vì thời gian đầu đấy là tôi chỉ gần như
là code cho nó thứ nhất là chạy được thứ
hai là chạy nhanh nên là thành ra là cái
việc clean thì nó không clean tạo là nó
khá là nhiều chick code ở trong đấy
nhiều cái mẹo thủ thuật code trong đấy
để cho
nó kiểu dạng là cho nó nó ngắn gọn và
nhanh như bù lại thì nó sẽ rất là khó
mọi người lấy cái biển danh của tôi là
giáo sư giáo sư Long code của giáo sư
Long nó một câu châm biếm như nửa nửa
đùa nửa kiểu cũng nghe cũng buồn khi mà
kiểu
à Mình nói chung là mình à mình vẫn là
ngựa non háu đá mình vẫn codt không được
kiểu thực sự là kiểu xịn nó lắm để cho
người khác có
thể hiểu được cái đoạn Nghiệp vụ đấy mà
mình làm cái đấy rất là
khó nói chung
là đấy Đấy là sự khác biệt giữa không
phải là Sino thì sẽ clean code đâu Tôi
nghĩ phải Master phải lên cái tầm mà
người ta nhìn được cái bài toán rộng hơn
rất nhiều và người ta biết được
là mình nên viết code như thế nào để cho
người người sau có thể đọc và hiểu được
thì tôi tôi Đương nhiên qua mức Junio
rồi Mức jio là code code chỉ cần chạy
được đúng không ạ đấy Hồi trước tôi hình
như tôi có từng định nghĩa cái đấy cho
sinh viên đối với tôi thì Junio là code
là code chạy được đấy và senio tức
C đương nhiên vẫn là COD chạy được rồi
là code ít bấc hơn
này
và tối ưu hơn đấy với tôi hiểu Master đ
nhên sẽ bao gồm tất cả điều trên và và
sẽ là code sạch hơn đó hồi trước tôi nhớ
là tôi khái niệm khác rất nhiều nhưng mà
đến bây giờ thì tôi khái niệm với tôi
thì nó sẽ như này code sạch hơn ở đây
không có nghĩa là hồi hồi trước tôi còn
thường hay bị nghĩ là kiểu à code ngắn
thì sẽ
sạch không Hồi trước tôi từng nghĩ như
này Nhưng mà thực ra sai hoàn
toàn tôi cũng có lấy một cái ví dụ Hồi
đấy tôi có dạy cho mấy ông hình như nó
có cái ví dụ này Ví dụ ở Giả sử Giả sử
nhá là để in ra sinh viện à để
đôi khi nó cũng là cái gì đó đấy đôi khi
chưa chắc ngắn đã đã dễ đọc dài dòng Nó
đi khi nó dễ đọc hơn đây ví dụ ví dụ
nhá
là nhập
đểa để thông
báo Đạt hay không đạt chẳng hạn thế bây
giờ giả sử code của jio nhá code J sẽ là
kiểu Ít
là điều kiện là lớn hơn 5 Giả sử thế đấy
thì đây chỉ cần đơn giản là như này Nếu
giả sử như
này Đây là codino
eo Đạt đúng không không không cần ki có
dấu đâu eo như này elo à nhầm nhầm nhầ
không đạt ch không đạt đâyo đạt đấy rất
ngắn
Ồ tôi sẽ cho thêm một cái nữa đây đii sẽ
có chia ở đây là ờ ba colum đi à đâu
đây Junior Ờ đây xio
đi thì sẽ
là điểm đạt bằng
này điểm hiện
tại này kêu
Còn với tôi với Tôi bây giờ sho viết thì
nó sẽ như nào À Master viết sẽ như nào
Tôi nghĩ là thế th nhá vì tôi chưa là
Master Tôi không biết
cái nó là nó gọi nhỉ ừ một là ông tách
nó ra thành một cái hàm riêng nên trong
trườ này thì gọn nhở
Ừ bây giờ giả sử là không nói về việc
tạo ra nhiều function tạo nhiều hàm
riêng đi nó sẽ như này điều kiện
[âm nhạc]
à thông báo thông báo Đạt nà À cái này
không Đạt nhỉ quên
cái này thì đây nếu mà nhỏ hơn nhỏ hơn
như này nhưng mà theo Tôi thường anh anh
leader tôi chỉ thì mình không nên mình
không nên kiểu kiểu phủ định phủ định
như này nó khó bị khó hiểu mình luôn làm
bài toán xuôi Happy cây các thứ thứ thì
nó sẽ là ưu tiên điều kiện Đạt lên đầu
trước rồi điều kiện không đạt như th
này
code này dài ăn tí code này dài vãi chưa
đúng không Nhưng mà ở đây nó sẽ là nếu
mà giả sử về sau đề bài thay đổi yêu cầu
khách hàng thay đổi kiểu thì khách hàng
chả thay đổi khách hàng không Trung Thủy
trước sau như một đâu đấy nó thay đổi
thì phải ông phải Ctrl f phải phải đi
ngồi mò chỗ nào có số 5 Chắc thế còn
không biết Hồi đấy là điều kiện là gì
đang đang nó ví dụ bài toán rất là đơn
giản đ nhá chứ làm gì có chuyện này
đi làm không làm mỗi cái bài toán này
thì bạn Ctrl f bạn tìm
đấy Sau đó thì bạn ngồi sửa điều kiện
các thứ các thứ đây vẫn chỉ đang ví dụ
đơn giản việc là chỉ in ra thông báo về
sau C làm những cái phức tạp hơn thì rõ
ràng ở đây nếu mà Master nó sẽ tạo ra
những function function riêng để thực
hiện cái Đạt này thực hiện cái không đạt
này Đấy các thứ các thứ nó sẽ rõ ràng
hơn rất nhiều còn đây chỉ là Giả etro
Eto
đấy thích để làm function như này cho
mấy ông dễ hình dung hơn à xử
lý xử lý khi đạt như này
Return là trả về
sớm mà đây sẽ là xử lý khi không đạt
chẳng
này early Return Tức là chỉ là mình ở
tại bước này mình dừng rồi mình không
nhảy xuống dưới nữa đấy Đây là code kiểu
Master đấy thế thế nên là nhiều lúc code
kiểu
dễ hiểu dễ đọc ấy thì chưa chắc là chưa
chắc là kiểu codt ngắn đâu thậm chí cả
điều kiện Đạt này chăng nữa tôi vẫn có
thể hoàn toàn là kiểu vă ch tên này kiểm
tra đạt như này đấy tôi sẽ trả về một
cái như này và đây sẽ
là kiểm tra đạt đó xa
đi
như này toàn bộ function function hết
code ở trong code chính cái hàm chính
của m ông chỉ có Hà gọi hàm gọi hàm như
này thôi mỗi hàm nó lại có chia nhỏ từng
dòng C Từng dòng C ra như này xử lý đấy
khi về sau ông muốn xử lý Giả sử ông xử
lý lúc mà khi đạt thì cần phải làm thêm
cái gì đó nữa thì ông vào đây ông sửa
khi không đạt thì ông làm gì đó nữa ông
vào cái hàm này ông sửa đấy ông thay đổi
điều kiện ông vào hàm này ông sửa đấy
thay đổi điểm đạt ông thay đổi trên cùng
trên cùng này nó sẽ dùng ở Nó nói biến
Global nó dùng ở mọi chỗ cũng là một
cách đấy Đây là code kiểu Master theo
theo tôi nghĩ là như thế bởi vì tôi chưa
lên cái tầm Master Nhưng mà tôi thấy là
đây là tôi thấy ở đây Đây mới gọi là
clean code là code rất dễ hiểu rất dễ
đọc còn đây thì cái này là bởi vì code
ông nó rất ngắn thì ông cảm thấy là code
này là ngắn gọn xúc tích dễ hiểu nhất
đúng không Nhưng mà sửa về sau rất là
khó về sau ông thay đổi không phải ngồi
mò trong
Nghìn không phải nghìn dòng code Mà có
rất nhiều file nữa đúng không Không phải
nhớ tên file mà Đấy là trong trường hợp
ông từng làm cái làm cái đấy rồi đó giả
sử là người khác làm sau đó thì ông vào
ông được đưa ra cái đề bài này đấy Kiểu
như thế ông phải Ngọ mò trong hàng trăm
đến là hàng trăm có thể thậm chí đến
hàng nghìn file để ông ngồi mò cái số
năm à xem ông kiểu đoạn nào đoạn xử lý
cái đoạn đấy à chẳng hạn thế chẳng hạn
thế nếu mà không ai đó chỉ ông thì ông
ngồi mò như thế đúng không Rồi thế chết
đấy Xong rồi xong rồi về sau Thay đổi
cái
á lại lại thay đổi cái kiểu lúc mà đạt
thì cần phải xử lý như thế nào nó phải
khác đi một tí
nó không phải mỗi thông báo Đạt nữa đúng
không đấy thì như th nào đấy Cái thứ
Xong rồi đến ngưỡng của xo là sao ngưỡng
sinio thì thường là nó cũng giống như
tôi bảo thì cũng có thể là thông báo khi
đạt ở
đây báo khi đạt Cũng có thể là nó lên
đến cái ngưỡng kiểu cũng như
thể không đạt
đi
đấy Cùng lắm là nó chỉ
này Thế kiểu mình sẽ khai báo những cái
mà có thể về sau dễ thay đổi Mình sẽ để
như này nhưng mà nó vẫn gọi
là nó vẫn không Mình vẫn phải đọc vào
code để hiểu cái logic nghiệp vụ cũng
như là về sau mình sửa một cái gì đó ví
dụ Giả sử về sau không thông báo thì thì
cái đoạn này Thành thừa đúng không lại
xóa
đi và và Hồi đấy tôi đọc là hạn chế x à
hạn chế eo nhất có thể hạn chế í lồng
trong íp hay Vân Vân Vân Vân Vân Nghĩa
là để nói chung là cái điều kiện lồng
điều kiện xong rồi điều kiện khác vân V
mình xử lý Dất điểm một cái mình sẽ trả
về sớm để hiểu được cái sau cái sau sẽ
là cái đương nhiên là cái ngược lại rồi
đấy mình sẽ xử lý dần dần dần dần nói
chung là
Ờ COD nó sẽ dài hơn khá nhiều nhưng về
sau ông sửa ông chỉ sửa ở một chỗ chỗ
khác chạy được đấy là quan điểm của tôi
hồi hồi đi học t rất lâu rồi hồi đi học
nhá không phải đi làm thôi nhá mà tôi đã
có quan điểm đấy Đó là làm Lập trình là
để khiến mình nhàn hơn nhưng mà nhàn ở
đây không phải Nhàn vật động não mà nhàn
hơn việc vật động mình ngồi một chỗ xong
rồi mình chỉ còn gõ gõ một tí là những
và gõ sao cho mà kiểu mình đỡ phải sửa
ít nhất có thể tất cả chỗ khác nó vẫn
phải hoạt động được chân chui bình
thường đấy thành ra thực ra là với cái
quan điểm từ hồi đi học của tôi đã là
như thế nên là khi mà đi làm thì tôi
cũng kiểu cũng muốn nó codt nó ngắn thì
đương nhiên có nhưng mà vẫn muốn sao cho
mà về sau khi sửa ít cần phải sửa nhất
có thể
và đương nhiên là bây giờ mà làm kiểu dễ
đọc dễ hiểu nữa thì quá tuyệt vời đúng
không ạ
tôi được Sếp tôi khai sáng và tôi cũng
kiểu muốn chia sẻ lại mấy ông ấy đó là
như tôi vừa đề cập đó là à việc là mình
sửa chỉ cần sửa một chỗ thôi tất cả chỗ
khác vẫn phải chạy được vẫn chạy ngon
lành đúng không ạ Làm thế nào để chắc
chắn điều đấy không phải là mình phải
test tất cả các tính năng khác bằng cách
thủ công đấy thế thế nên là tôi mới
thường hay dạy mấy ông V gần đây có khái
niệm là viết test ấy các thứ các thứ bây
giờ tôi viết test hô ví dụ Điển hôm nay
này tôi vừa khoe xếp tôi là kiểu Ờ tôi
vừa viết một cái đoạn
test test tận 12 cái trường hợp cho mỗi
cái tính năng này nhá mài test tận 12
trường hợp luôn đấy cho nó chắc đấy
nghĩa thm chỉ là kiểu Khi mà mình kiểu
viết để bắt được những cái kiểu trường
hợp rất là dị luôn của khách các thứ các
thứ để khi mà mình để code lên gần như
là khách trừ khi khách về sau phải cũng
dị lắm để nghĩ ra thêm cái trường hợp
khác và khi khách mà giả sử khách vẫn
làm được của Gây ra được bấc để mà làm
lỗi được code mình thì tôi sẽ sinh ra
cái trường hợp thứ 18 13 14 à đâu 12 nhỉ
Ừ thì 13 14 để để khắc phục nó và khi có
test các thứ thấy ngon lành đúng không v
sau mấy ông đẩy code lên yên tâm lắm Bởi
vì bởi vì các bạn chỉ cần chạy lại test
tất cả các các test đều mà pass đều qua
thì thì chứng tỏ là code code mới các
bạn xịn rồi nghĩa là không gây ảnh hưởng
đến cái kiểu tính năng cũ đúng không ạ
nghĩa sửa một chỗ những chỗ khác vẫn
chạy được đấy Đấy là quan điểm đơ giảng
của
tôi n Thực ra nói ít tâm sự vẫn khá
nhiều nhé nhưng mà tâm sự về code Chắc
mấy ông cũng không khó chịu gì đâu ở đấy
Thực ra tôi muốn nói trước hôm nay Thực
ra lúc đầu tôi định muốn nói trước về
cái mục đích kênh blog của tôi trước khi
mà kiểu dạy hay làm mọi thứ Thực ra là
tôi
không Tôi đã từng nói với mấy ông hình
như một lần một lần mục đích lập ra kênh
này rồi
Chắc là bây giờ tôi sẽ nói lại có thể nó
sẽ khác với cái thời đấy ai cũng thay
đổi mà nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi vẫn thường
hay bảo là tôi luôn thay đổi nên theo
trườ hướng tốt lên tôi vẫn là tôi nhưng
mà theo trườ hướng tốt lên không nhưng
mà thực ra vừa nãy tôi cũng không nhớ
được là tôi lúc mà tôi ghi chú lại cái
ghi chú lại cái cái câu này này lúc Vy
Tôi nghĩ ra được cái gọi là
cái cái ý nghĩa hay lắm Bây giờ thì quên
mấtt cái ý nghĩa đấy rồi
à Nhưng mà tôi vẫn nhớ được
cái lý do đầu tiên cái A cái lý do đầu
tiên để tôi tạo tạo ra thứ nhất là kênh
YouTube này Thứ hai là tại sao tôi lại
đổi tên và đặt tên kênh YouTube hay là
kênh
Nói chung là fanpage các thứ của tôi nó
là như thế
vừa xem lại mấy cái Vlog cũ của anh JV
evermine nữa th tôi lại cà nhớ lại ừ nó
đó chính là lý do của tôi thì để tôi
chia sẻ lại lý do nhé đầu tiên thì hồi
trước lý do kênh YouTube này ra đời thì
đó là hồi đấy là đợt dịch bên J2 the
team community kiểu dạng là muốn thử
kiểu dạng anh Tuấn muốn kiểu dạng là dạy
online nên
là kiểu à đâ đầu tiên là tạo ra nhóm
nhóm đúng
nhỉ À không đúng rồi vẫn dạy online qua
kênh discord thì phải thôi tự nhiên tôi
quên mất là kênh discorde tạo ra cùng
ngày hôm đấy không Hình như là hình như
là không kênh discord tạo ra trước sau
đó thì mới C th hướng lên muốn dạy
online thì Lúc đầu định định dạy online
qua
kênh discord đấy Đúng
dạy trực tuyến qua discord thì nó kiểu
cái nhược điểm đầu tiên
à Cái nhược điểm đầu tiên là
kiểu bị giấy há lượn người xem chứ cũng
không cũng không nghĩ đến với việc là
kiểu sẽ lưu lại video cũ để cho người
khác xem lại đâu lúc đấy thì muốn xem
kiểu muốn dạy trực tuyến kiểu dạy trực
tiếp
ấy kiểu livestream các thứ các thứ nhưng
mà bị giới hạn được xem nên là bắt đầu
chuyển qua kênh
YouTube chuyển qua kênh YouTube này thì
lúc đầu tôi bảo anh đấy là bọn mình lập
một kênh
riêng kiểu ch high school sau đó thì tất
cả mọi người dạy dạy vào trong kênh trên
đấy như anh ấy bảo là thôi Dùng kênh cá
nhân đi Chắc là anh ấy nói chung là tôi
cảm thấy là tôi may mà tôi thường hay
làm việc được với con người có tâm nhìn
rất là xâu xa như thế chắc là kiểu anh
ấy cứ gọi như nào gần đây tôi cũng thấy
định hướng của bên Gần đây tôi mới để ý
để ý Có vài định hướng của vài bên khá
hay Đó là kiểu là giống như ex Channel
một điển hình đó là chỉ là cho những
thành viên nhân viên của mình tự tạo ra
kênh riêng để họ khi mà họ phát triển
kênh riêng
ấy Họ sẽ tự mình biết được Ừ nó là của
mình Nó là đứa con mình mình phải kiểu
kiểu có tranh nhiệm với nó chăm sóc nó
các thứ thứ ấ và có tâm với nó các thứ
thứ hơn chứ nếu mà giả sử là kênh kênh
chung ấy kiểu kênh của công ty hay là
kênh chung các thứ thứ thế thì ai cũng
kiểu dễ bị đù đùn đẩy trách nhiệm và
nghĩ rằng là nhỡ đâu về sau mình nghỉ
việc thì nó không thì nó không còn là
của mình nữa thì mình không cần phải gắn
bó nó quá Chắc thế Chắc thế nên là nên
là kiểu dạng là phát triển kênh riêng V
Tôi thấy vẫn khá là ổn miễn là kiểu miễn
là vẫn đương nhiên là vẫn kiểu quảng cáo
hã giới thiệu về công ty hay các th
thứ Còn việc đặt tên là Block như thế
Thực ra thì mấy Ông Nếu mấy ông tra khái
niệm về Block với Vlog
bây giờ nó khách nó như nào rồi
người còn bị nhầm Vlog này là chỉ là
kiểu Anh
Việt Trần Đức Việt à à anh jvi đấy à có
chữ vên thành Vlog
tôi tra cái từ Vlog này này nó thể hiện
là việc
là C gần đây bây giờ tra tôi mới thấy tự
nhiên có chữ livestream chứ hồi trước
tôi tra Tôi nhớ Vlog là nó chỉ là kiểu
là Daily Daily nghĩa là kiểu hàng ngày ấ
còn Block là kiểu dạng thỉnh thoảng mình
mình đăng nội dung hơn nhớ là
thế sao bây giờ nó khác
trữ
chữ nó kiểu bị nói chung chung ấy chứ
không phải tôi ngại đọc Thái chữ
bao gồm không phải mỗi video các thứ các
thứ sẽ kiểu sẽ nói về một chủ đề nhất
định kiểu kểu dạng như một cái nhật ký
các thứ thứ chia sẻ nội dung kiểu về cả
chữ nữa chứ không phải là hoặc hình ảnh
nữa chứ không phải về mỗi video Ừ hình
như thế Vlog Chắc là viết tắt của cả từ
video à kiểu
thế mục đích này À để truyền tải các thứ
thứ
đọc
hơn nội dung này thứ thứ à phải viết đ
thứ viết tôi rất là kém thì tôi chỉ 5
phẩy văn và tôi nghĩ là 57 Văn đấy chắc
là có thể là do giáo viên Vì mình không
thường hay viết theo ý của giáo viên
nhưng mà nói chung là văn mình thì không
văn vở lắm tôi chắc là chỉ lươn thôi Tôi
không giỏi vắn
là như thế nghĩa là
kiểu tôi tôi lúc đầu tôi muốn giống anh
JV Tức là chỉ là quay nói về những cái
mình quan tâm chia sẻ suy nghĩ ý kiến
của bản thân mình nhưng nhưng mà tôi
không hẳn là muốn chỉ làm mỗi video và
tôi sẽ cả nếu bạn xem theo dõi Fanpage
của tôi là tôi sẽ cập nhật trên đấy
Kiểu những cái mà tôi cảm thấy hay ho
tôi cũng sẽ đăng lên đấy chia sẻ lại các
thứ và đưa ra góp nhìn quan điểm bằng
chữ chứ không phải là video nữa nên là
tôi muốn hướng đến là sẽ là kiểu
blog kênh kênh này hiện tại thì vẫn mang
thên hướng là giống kiểu dạy học này
nhiều hơn à hoặc chia sẻ kiểu về code là
nhiều nhưng mà tôi không hẳn là muốn
kênh chỉ dừng ở góp độ đấy mà nó sẽ là
đạng à Nó gọi là à Đúng rồi hôm trước
tôi chắc là tôi có nhớ mang máng cái lúc
mà tôi ghi cái dòng này tôi nhớ lý do
rồi Nó làm chỉ là tôi
muốn cho cũng gần giống như là Daily tức
là kiểu cái nhật ký hàng ngày là cho mấy
ông biết được cuộc sống của
một của một người đấy một coder nó sẽ
như thế nào chẳng hạn thế chắc là về
chắc là về sau như tôi đã từng hứa tôi
không biết tôi hứa mấy ông chưa n tôi
từng hứa với bạn tôi các thứ các thứ là
tôi có mua tôi có đầu tư mua con iPhone
và mua định mua cả cái con ch à
ch lắm không
nhớ không phải chort cái con cầm tay đây
Con con này à không phải con cầm này đâu
Con này là gì nh gim gim
à À gimbo gimbo gimbo đấy để mà sẽ là
quay video kiểu dạng là các thứ
à để mà quay lại kiểu có sống kiểu dạng
tôi không hẳn là quay Cuộc sống đâu Tôi
không không quan tâm vế việc là kiểu à
Tôi không nghĩ là mấy hôm rảnh nỗi để
ngồi xem cuộc sống tôi nha vì cuộc sống
tôi chẳng có gì cả nhưng mà
À Ý tôi là tôi có thể tôi sẽ quay các
thứ
thứ nhiều hơn à quay kiểu mình thấy cái
gì chứ không phải quay mặt tôi chắc là
thế như đại khái là ý tôi là mục đích
lập ra kênh như thế nghĩa là sẽ có những
những cái video mà Mấy ông có thể thấy
nó phù hợp Ví dụ việc dạy học này thấy
phù hợp hay là thỉnh thoảng mấy ông thấy
tâm sự cũng thể phù hợp còn việc chia sẻ
góc nhìn thì thì tôi thấy là không phải
ai cũng gọi
là suy nghĩ quan điểm như thế chắc chắn
rồi nên là tôi nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ chia
sẻ góc nhìn của tôi m không thấy là góp
nhìn của tôi có thể là sai lệch có chắc
chắn là có rất nhiều cái sai lệch tôi
cặp cảm thấy thế nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy
là tôi cần được nói ra Tôi cần có một
nơi để chia sẻ và tôi thích kiểu Tôi
thích nói tôi thích chia sẻ thì tôi cứ
nói ra thôi nôi nói ra Không Phải khẳng
định là tôi đúng và mấy không sai nó là
nà giống như là cái hồi trước tôi nhớ là
tôi có cái ghi ở đây nó cái có khái niệm
là như là ở đây tôi hình như tôi xóa mất
rồi hồi trước tôi có nói hình như tôi có
nói vụ đấy rồi đó là ở đây bản chất là
tôi vẫn đang nói mấy ông vẫn đang lắ
nghe nên thành ra nó vẫn hơi bị kiểu
kiểu nó một chiều ấy Tức là chỉ hoàn
toàn tôi thể thao túng mấy
ông kiểu nghe tôi và nó nó kiểu dạng là
tôi cảm thấy không thích điều đấy lắm
chuẩn là tôi đưa ra ý kiến rồi xong rồi
chúng ta kiểu cùng nhau trao đổi cùng
nhau thảo luận thì vẫn là vẫn là kiểu
một quan đệ hai chiều vẫn là tốt nhất
đúng không ạ Tôi nghĩ là nên
một tuần một
video Mr
code ơ nhở nãy giờ con chưa cốt gì ngồi
ba hoa chích chò nhều
thế chắc là tôi sẽ viết lại văn bản nó
kiểu nghe nó mượt mà hơn khi nói này
nghe cũng vẻ hay lắm nhưng mà đọng lại
chắc là nó nãy giờ nó cứ kiểu bị rời rạc
ấy n chắc là tôi sẽ cố Hôm nào tôi nghĩ
tôi sẽ viết lại cái này chỉnh châ hơn à
Có video này ông xem nhá tôi mới gì gọi
mấy ông xem trước đã xong rồi tí tôi
cũng sẽ nói video này bây giờ code đã
nhỉ Thế là cũng bị lười vì tính ra hôm
nay tôi code khá
nhiều không phải lười code đâu mà làm
chỉ là não mình ấy não mình tôi tôi
thường n có khái niệm đó là Đó là kiểu
dạng là
điểm thì não mình nó
sẽ thông minh nhưng mà thông minh Chỉ
dạng đấy tầm 6 B tiếng trong ngày hay
vân vân gì gì đó thôi nghĩa một khoảng
thời gian nhất định trong khoảng thời
gian nhất định và giới hạn ở trong ngày
thôi Mấy ông không nên kiểu ui hôm nay
tao làm được việc tao sẽ ngồi cầy các
thứ thứ tranh thủ ngồi cầy làm món não
rất bị quá tải và và gọi nhở ông sử dụng
Thế cũng gọi là hơi phá quá thế nên là
thế nên là về sau gọi nhờ nhiều người
đúng có khái niệm là hồi trẻ thông minh
còn về già lúi lẫn à Mấy ông biết khái
niệm đấy Không em chỉ mình sử dụng chất
xám rồi kiểu suy nghĩ bị kiểu làm nặng
đầu quá ấy kiểu nghĩ nhiều quá ấy nhưng
mà nó không giải quyết được gì mà nhưng
mà mình vẫn kiểu tranh thủ nghĩ các thứ
làm cho não bị kiểu quá tải thì về sau
về sau Kiểu cái cái nói chung là n ông
một là ông quen được điều đấy dù ông có
quen được điều đấy nhưng mà về sau lâu
dài thì nó vẫn không tốt đúng không nên
tôi tôi thường hay kiểu nghĩa là kiểu có
nhiều cái thì mình cứ để giống như xếp
tôi ấ xếp Tôi bảo là trong công việc thì
anh sử dụng não còn ngoài đời thì anh cứ
vô ch thôi vì lúc ấy anh sẽ vứt não đi
để cho não nghỉ ngơi cũng là một
cách à nãy giờ không trả lời bình luận
mấy bạn đ trả lời anh có thể mô tả luồng
hoạt động của chức năng quét QR để thanh
toán trên mấy trang bán hàng được không
ạ Ờ bản chất ở qu Gear này nó theo mình
thì nó vẫn là bản chất nó link nó nó một
đường dẫn link để nhảy đến một cái link
nào đó và một cái C nào đó để mà xử lý
chứ nó cũng không hẳn cái gì đó quá ghê
gớm
cả
lel trong tương lai có c ổn không nganh
Ờ lel trọng
tướng Hiện tại thì lel được cho rằng là
là kiểu Framework cũng vừa lớn mạnh và
cộng đồng rất là lớn mạnh của
p Nếu mà để mà nói thì phải hỏi cũng
phải hỏi sâu hơn là pp trong tương lai
nó vẫn còn được sử dụng hay không à Theo
mình
thì thứ nhất là không nói về việc là hồi
trước toàn bị giật tít là 70 PH trong
trong website trên thế giới vẫn đang
dùng pp Thực ra cái đấy Nó kiểu nó nó
bao gồm rất nhiều WordPress mấy cái mì
ăn liền kiểu magento các thứ thứ Nên là
bỏ cái vụ đấy đi nếu mà chỉ Thuần về
những trang web sử dụng lel trên thế
giới thực ra là nó không Tôi không nghĩ
là lên đến nổi 10 ph đâu
nhưng
mà Khoan nói về công nghệ chúng ta là
lập trình viên chúng ta N không phụ
thuộc mình và công nghệ hay ngôn ngữ vì
ngôn ngữ hay công nghệ mọi thứ theo tôi
theo như sếp tôi nói và tôi cảm thấy gần
đây tôi đã bớt bờ thủ hơn V vấn đề đấy
Nó làm chỉ là mình là lập trình viên là
mình không tôi đang nói không đến 10 chứ
không phải 10 ph
đấy
nghĩa là là mình lập trình viên tức là
chị mình là người viết mã để cho máy
tính hiểu đấy đúng không ạ developer tức
là nhà phát triển mà chứ không phải là
nhà bảo thủ đâu nghĩa là chỉ là mình
phải dựa trên những cái gì mà mình đang
có sẵn mình thể phát triển nâng cấp nó
lên đấy Đấy là theo lý thuyết của lập
trình viên theo như tôi nhớ deer ấy đấy
thôi h trước tôi có nói mế ông rồi Gần
đây Thực ra chính tôi bị đi vào vết xe
đấy mấy ông nhớ với khái niệm developer
với coder không ạ deer là chỉ là nhà
phát triển tức là á chỉ là mình sẽ luôn
phát triển bản thân mình hơn là mới bản
thân mình hơn th và phát triển cái phần
mềm theo chiếu hướng là kiểu dạng là tốt
hơn các thử các thứ và tự bản thân mình
cũng phát triển mình hơn để phù hợp với
cái kiểu dạng là xu thế hay là công nghệ
các thứ thứ đấy còn coder thì là người
gõ code thôi Nó giống kiểu nh thư ký chỉ
gõ lại những cái gì mà
họ hiểu họ biết và họ nghe đọc kiểu nghe
đọc ấy đấy Nên là nên là rất nhiều Đúng
là hồi trước tôi thường hay chơi coder
nhưng mà tôi đúng bây giờ x Ly Tôi chỉ
biết mui p với ra Script th không ổn lắm
chắc là tôi cũng sẽ phải học thêm ngôn
ngữ nữa để có cái nhìn hơn chứ không thì
tôi bắt đầu giống coder rồi chỉ biết gõ
và làm những cái thứ gì mình đã biết
Ờ tôi hôm trước có gặp anh Minh Minh mon
men Nếu mà hôm trước không xem thì có
nghe tôi giới thiệu với anh đấy thì anh
đấy có nói với tôi là anh ấy từng gặp
một anh kỹ sư Microsoft à Anh Kỹ sư Việt
Nam từng làm việc cho Microsoft anh ấy
không không còn gọi anh đâu phải Bá bởi
vì anh ấy kiểu à vì rất là lớn tuổi cũng
60 70 rồi Rất rất giỏi nhưng mà Bởi vì
họ là một trong những người đời đầu đúng
không nhở không nhớ là người Việt hay
người gì nữa nhưng mà đại khái là giỏi
giỏi nhất ở đây không phải là về ngôn
ngữ lập chính mà giỏi nhất đây là về SQL
Ui chung cái SQL mình thích luôn ạ Đấy
nghe cuốn nghĩa là người ta kiểu viết
SQL rất là chuyên nghiệp rất là đỉnh và
đỉnh đến nỗi đó là mấy có biết không ạ
đó là SQL bản chất là nó cũng giống như
là một ngôn ngữ lập trình được Tức là nó
vẫn có biến nó vẫn có vòng lặp nó vẫn có
điều kiện đ các th thứ đang hỏa đấy thế
nên là người ta viết eql Đỉnh Đến nỗi
thế người ta bị lạm dụng và người ta
cũng kiểu theo chủ nghĩa tôn thờ ấy theo
chủ nghĩa kiểu chủ nghĩa gì không nhớ
lắm đúng không nhở Không biết chủ nghĩa
tôn thờ không chủ nghĩa tôn
rồi sợ kiểu đụng chạm quá ờ nh đại khái
là thế nghĩa là người ta tự tin vào bản
thân và kiểu cũng hơi bỏ thổ đi
đấy trình độ SQL của mình nên là Mọi thứ
ông ấy đều viết bằng fql kể cả xử lý bất
kỳ cái gì khác muốn làm tính năng gì
Muốn làm website gì Ông ấy rất thành
thạo về pp mmin mấy ông nhớ kết quả pp
mmin đúng không ạ Ông ấy làm trang pp m
Min rất là đỉnh cao để mà nó phân quyền
các thứ thứ mọi người vào đấy hoàn toàn
có đầy đủ tính năng để thao tác vân vân
Nhưng
mà rõ ràng là làm bằng ngôn ngữ khác có
thể chỉ hai ba dòng code là được đấy
nhưng mà không ông ấy vẫn phải muốn lôi
SQL vào để xử xử lý các thứ thứ thấy thế
nên là nó rất là dài
Ừ kiểu thế mấy ông hình dụng ạ vì người
ta chỉ biết thạo về SQL và người ta nhá
người ta thích thế đấy người ta tôn sùng
nó đúng không ngườ ta làm mọi thứ bằng
nó đấy đấy cũng tính là một coder đấy
không phải là developer nữa họ không
phát triển bản thân lên họ vẫn chìm đắm
ở trong cái công nghệ cũ những cái thứ
mà họ biết rồi đấy x họ cứ dùng đi dùng
lại nó kể cả d Nó lỗi thời rồi
đấy theo tôi thì mình không đi vào vết
xe đổ L được mình hiểu được nhưng mà tôi
không nói về bài toán là chúng ta thi lu
luôn phải cập nhật công nghệ rồi chạy
theo xu thế không cần nhưng mà chỉ là
khi mà mình cần thay đổi thì mình thay
đổi mình đừng có bám buộc vào kiểu cố
nưu kéo cái cũ xôi nếu thế nó thành bị
báo thủ mất rồi đúng không
s hẳn thì lúc đấy
Ruby mới chiếm chỗ P Tôi không biết là
mấy khái niệm này như thế nào nó rộng
team school Ừ tôi thấy là kiểu rất nhiều
ông ở đây đương nhiên là tôi là một
người vô danh rồi toàn bộ mọi người biết
nên tôi thông qua J2 team community xong
rồi X rồi Từ đấy biết thêm cả J high
school Đúng không ạ Rồi tôi Câ K cũng
lôi kéo câu kéo được khá nhiều ông theo
dõi tôi Ví dụ mình m mấy nghìn người đấy
theo dõi tôi nhưng mà chắc là lượng
người xem bỏ qua lượng người xem trực
tiếp bởi vì không phải Ai có thời gian
xem trực tiếp nhưng mà chắc là lượn
người xem thường xuyên tôi chắc chỉ trăm
người là là nhiều đấy chứ không Bởi vì
kiến thức này cà nó cũng càng kiểu nó
không phải là ừ kiểu dạng là ai nghe
được đúng không
làm thực thể
th thực thể á thực thế về lal api
backend thì lấy data từ nhiều bảng ba
bảng trở lên thì dùng ch ha relationship
ạ
Ờ tôi có chia sẻ mấy ông rồi
relationship là tốt nhất đối của thằng
lar à The kiểu ngon n kiểu là tiện các
thứ thứ mà phù hợp cho việc về sau có
thể kết nối sang nhiều database khác các
thứ thứ rất Nói chung là nó làm khá là
rất là ổn việc Là tối ưu cho việc sử
dụng được nhiều cơ s có thể thay thế
linh hoạt hay sử dụng nhiều cơ sở liệu
nhưng mà nó không tối ưu về việc tốc độ
nên thực sự bạn quan tâm về tốc độ thì
bạn sẽ phải viết join nhưng mà join phải
rất là cẩn thận vì nó không sử dụng cái
Global Scope hay bất kỳ cái Scope nào
của thằng mod cũng như là sau bạn thay
đổi gì thằng B là coi như là cần phải
cẩn thận cái vụ Joi dùng các thứ thế Nói
chung phải rất tự tin thì mới dùng Joi
còn không cứ dùng relation ship cho
Ờ có nguồn tài liệu về best practice với
cul hay
ờ chính bản thân mình mình cũng cũng
muốn là xem mấy cái best practice của
larel nhưng mà hồi trước là là tôi có
theo dõi vài kênh larel đấy nhưng mà Mấy
kênh đấy lại quen việc dạy chỉ dành cho
kiểu fesser quá nên là thực ra tôi cũng
hủy theo rõi
rồi bây giờ để mà để mấy ông xem ấy thì
mấy ông phải vào hẳn mấy cái Open x nào
của larel ví dụ của mấy cái kiểu hôm
trước tôi có chia sẻ mới ông là tôi cũng
thường hay đánh dấu sao cho mấy cái Pit
ấy có rất nhiều packit Tôi vẫn mang
Thiên hướng là packit nào mà tôi hiểu
thì tôi đánh dấu vào ví dụ Giả sử là đây
sparty nhóm sparty hay gì đấy Nói chung
mấy ông xem ngôn ngữ ở đây thậm chí ngôn
ngữ không phải p cũng được mấy ông vào
xem để cách người ta người ta code như
th nào không nhất thiết phải larel mà
đúng không ạ Thật ra larel nó chỉ là fw
thôi Xem cách người ta kiểu viết code
như th nào là hợp lý
xuyên kiểm tra tin nhắn với kênh discord
mà có gì Các bạn cứ nhắn không đấy em có
một offer công việc ở trong Nam nhưng bố
lại không ch việc vì kiểu ông cũng tuổi
kiểu cơ hội để phát triển cho sự nghiệp
với bản thân em Nhưng mà quan trọng là
như nà nhỉ
nhiều kinh nghiệm và nó không chắc là
lâu dài được nên là việc là mình di
chuyển như thế cũng như là người khác
phải di chuyển theo mình giả sử Thế thì
cũng sẽ tôn kém các th thứ ở h Hà Nội là
ở trong ngoài Bắc này Thực ra là mình
biết mình biết vài nơi cũng tuyển nhưng
vài nơi tuyển gắt thì cũng có tôi không
có hồi trước là tôi có nhớ tôi làm cái
vụ kết nối len để hỗ trợ cho các bạn còn
bây giờ tôi cũng bỏ cái linken đấy khá
là lâu rồi và mấy cái job đấy hình như
nó cũng không còn không còn nữa đây tôi
tôi đúng kiểu tội đồ luôn ạ Tôi nhớ là
cuối thô K trai lầ là cũng bảy mươi mấy
tin nhắn tôi để đấy bởi vì tôi nghĩ là
tôi sẽ kiểu sẽ trả lời để cho Để hỗ trợ
các bạn sau ấy nhưng mà nhưng mà không
có thời gian trả lời và Tôi tin là mấy
cái mấy cái đấy nó cũng hết hạn
rồi Hơi khó
không không biết hỗ trợ mấy ông kiểu gì
Ngoài việc là khuyên mấy ông a phải tro
dối kiến thức để cạnh tranh nhau thôi
chính mấy ông đang cạnh tranh nhau ấy
nên là nên là ông nào gọi nhỉ Tự tin tự
tin được đi trước được mạnh gọi đi nhanh
hơn được người ăn thôi chứ tôi không
biết khuyên cái gì nữa Ôi có chữ pro này
trố xị này cái này hình chư Hồi trước là
từng từng được cái từng tham gia cái gói
Vip nào
đấy x đâ trong
à trong
xị được đấy tôi sẽ thêm mấy
cái thêm vào trong cái list này nữa à
đâu à lit này beta hay
nhỉ Nhưng mà thêm vào trong list này
kiểu
hay
à nghĩa vào vào và đánh dấu thì
phải được tôi sẽ cho mấy cái này vào vào
thêm cái list này hay
đó tôi sẽ thêm vào đây để mấy ông vào
xem xem nhá
quên mất
đấy quên tạo mấy cái list cá thử
thử
chưa ngồi cốt gì cả thôi để buổi sau nhá
Hôm nay thứ năm à sang tuần thực ra là
tôi định Tuần sau tôi còn chỉ chỉ tâm sự
cơ tâm sự về về đời sống và về tết các
thứ
thứ mấy ông Sắp Tết rồi mấy ông suy nghĩ
thế nào ạ suy nghĩ rất nhiều cái suy
nghĩ về năm Ngo năm trước thế nào và suy
nghĩ về
à Cái dự định Sắp Tết của ông Sang năm
mọi thứ như thế
thì có thể học pp được không anh
Ờ tôi có cái khóa tôi có tạo cái Play
playlist web cơ bản ấy thì tôi có dạy CS
với JavaScript cơ bản ấy thì ông có thể
học cái đấy và trong đấy nó sẽ dạy pp
nữa Nói chung là mình kiểu gì mình vẫn
phải biết làm giao diện cơ bản đã thì
mình mới làm vụ hiển thị rồi chứ Chứ làm
pp không thuần thì làm sao mà làm hiển
thị được đúng không ạ Còn tôi dạy thì
mấy ông sẽ thấy là tôi dạy chuyên về
backend tôi không dạy chuyên về fan là
cũng không đề cập đến CS với javascrip
nhiều
anh nhỉ ờ học Java xin ngon lành chứ
Java là cái thứ gọi là tính là Đấy mới
gọi là không gọi là ngôn ngữ chết kểu là
học Java tôi thấy là nếu mà định hướng
đấy tôi gần đây tôi có nói mấy ông ạ
định hướng Tôi học ngôn ngữ tôi sẽ học
Java bởi vì nó khá là chặt chẽ và tốt
không phải để kiếm việc mà code kiểu
dạng là hiểu rõ bản chất lập trình chuẩn
chỉ nhất đấy nên Lài sẽ học Java và học
Java xong thì nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác
khá là dễ bởi vì ngôn ngữ Java tính mức
độ sao n sẽ là tôi đánh giá là ba
sao P và Python thì tôi đánh giá là một
sao người khác biết Python đánh ra thế
Tôi không biết Python nhưng mà tôi đánh
giá thế JavaScript thì có thể một hoặc
hai sao gì gì đó n là Java nó khác khó
nhưng mà Học để hiểu được nó xong thì
làm làm việc mọi thứ rất là chuẩn chỉ ổn
và rất nhiều công ty
mới và một đồng thứ lòng nhàng đi kèm
theo
đang ở trong cái giai đoạn bất ổn ở đó
giai đoạn đầy thử thách hay vân vân vân
Nhưng mà tôi Tôi nghĩ theo đương nhiên
là theo góc nhìn của tôi thôi theo kiểu
tính cách của tôi nữa đó
là tôi không bao giờ bị nản trước một
đống thử thách hay một Đống việc hay là
Vân Vân các thứ thế Kể cả việc Kể cả
việc tôi không thích nhá không phải mỗi
việc lập trình Tôi thích này tôi có để
theo
được Tôi không bị nản bởi trước mấy đúng
đấy tôi chỉ bị nản khi mà tôi cảm thấy
có những cái thứ không thể gọi là không
thể giải quyết được kiểu không không
biết không phải không biết bắt đầu từ
đâu đâu mà là có nhiều người biết được
bắt đầu mà chẳng qua họ ngại họ không
bắt đầu ấy chứ họ ngại Sợ thất bại hay
Vân Vân rất nhiều thứ chứ tôi không sợ
thất bại tôi không sợ Ngại mấy điều đấy
à tôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi chỉ sợ về khoản là
tôi hồi trước tôi từng nói khái niệm là
đừng bao giờ để mình vào cái Thế gọi là
bất lực kiểu dạng là không thể kiểu thay
đổi được nữa sẽ về sau mấy ông đôi khi m
ông sẽ bị rơi vào tình huống đấy Nếu giả
sử Bây giờ ông không thay đổi chẳng hạn
thế về sau ông sẽ có thể rơi vào cái
tình huống đấy nĩa là lúc đấy ông muốn
thay đổi không thay đổi nữa Đấy là tình
trạng bất lực tình trạng không thể làm
được gì nữa không có gì để cứu vãn được
nữa cứu vãn mọi thứ bây giờ khó khăn và
gần như không thể
đấy đấy mới là cái thứ tôi sợ nhất
Hồi trước tôi tôi kể mấy ông rồi chắc là
tôi vẫn phải kể lại đó là kiểu tôi tôi
cũng xuất thân không phải dấu có rất là
khó khăn thiếu thốn rất nhiều vấn đề các
thứ Nên là hồi bé mà ngồi xem với cái
kiểu hồi bé được xem nhá chứ không phải
là kiểu bây giờ có tiktok được xem đâu
là kiểu dạng là là việc
mình kiếm được người mình yêu mình
thương nhưng mà không muôn đăng hộ đối à
Rồi vân vân rồi Kiểu kiểu gia đình nhà
gái khinh mình à Hay coi thường mình vân
vân mình không phải chủ tịch để mà th
bật lại nên là tôi cảm thấy tôi không
bao giờ muốn rơi vào mấy cái hoàn cảnh
như thế đấy lý do mà tôi Tôi không thể
nói Đấy lý do tôi phấn đấu được vì lúc
mà tôi phấn đấu Tôi không nhớ đến cái lý
do đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà
À có rất nhiều cái tác động ngầm và cái
tiềm thức của mình để mình cảm thấy là
cái này nó quá bé nhỏ để mình để đánh
bại được mình kểu thế tôi chẳng ngại mấy
cái điều đấy vì tôi nghĩ là có rất nhiều
cái thứ nó kinh khủng hơn rất nhiều đấy
nên là tôi không những cái câu hỏi mà
mấy ông đang đặt cho tôi bây giờ cái
thời tôi đi học có đa số là tôi không
nghĩ đến điều đấy đâu Tôi chỉ nghĩ là
việc là tôi có muốn làm cái đấy hoặc
không muốn làm thôi chứ tôi không nghĩ
việc khó Hay Khổ gì đâu thật tôi không
quan điểm như thế năm nhất tôi cũng đã
làm việc học học bơ nhá không phải làm
lập trình mà năm tôi kể mấy ông năm nhất
là tôi đi là bồi bàn Tôi đi làm qu bar
tôi tôi chạy tôi chạy tôi gồng đến nỗi
kiểu sau hai tuần làm cực lực K kiểu là
tôi không ngồi nghỉ luôn Nghĩa là nghĩa
là tôi làm còn ba đ 8 tiếng
à 8 tiếng một
ngày theo như theo như quy định là hạn
hạn chế ngồi chơi nhất có thể chứ người
ta trả tiền mình không phải để mình ngồi
chơi nên là tôi cũng không ngồi luôn 8
tiếng tôi chỉ đứng kiếm việc để làm kể
không có khách thì tôi chạy đi lau hoặc
lau dọn hoặ tôi để cái gì gì đó tôi
không ngồi luôn không ng nghỉ nên là sau
hai tuần tôi bị tôi bị Team con h xong
rồi tôi đi khám thì tôi phát hiện tôi bị
thiếu máu vì làm việc cực lực quá đấy
Đấy đấy là một cái Điển hình Vic Tôi cảm
thấy tôi gồng khi mà tôi vào một công
việc kì đó kể cả nó không phù hợp tôi
vẫn gồng hết sức có
thể kiểu chỉ có sức khỏe Nó không đáp
ứng được thì đành chịu thôi
Ờ nghĩa tôi chẳng ngại m cái kiểu thế
cho lắm
Thực ra còn gồng khỏe hơn tôi nói chung
là mọi thứ hơn tôi nhưng mà họ nhưng mà
cũng gọi là
à có người thì ý chí Tôi cảm thấy là tôi
có thể hơn họ tôi cảm thấy là tôi con
người sống theo kiểu là duy tâm tức là
HM chị là tôi nghĩ rằng là ý chí mình có
thể quyết định rất là nhiều thứ nên là
thành ra tôi sống nh C chủ nghĩa như thế
là mình mình tin là mình làm được đầu
tiên mình phải tin đã mình à mình tin
mình làm được xong rồi mình cứ thế làm
cho đến khi mà đến một cái mà mình đến
gọi là mình sẽ đặt một cái danh giới một
cái giới hạn nào đó khi mà đến hẳn
dananh giới đấy mà mình cảm thấy là nó
đến ranh giới rồi đến ngưỡng rồi thì
mình mới bắt đầu buông ví dụ Giả sử Hồi
trước mà tôi kể vụ là tôi đi làm thực
tập ở một công ty nó bóc lột đến nỗi là
lúc đầu chỉ 500.000 Xong về sau chỉ 1
triệu tiền trợ cấp mà trong khi đó tiền
ăn chưa mỗi tháng là 600
đấy tôi vẫn làm cho đến khi mà nó đến
cái ngưỡng giới hạn thì 6 tháng rồi mình
cũng học được rất nhiều thứ rồi cảm thấy
là cũng cứng rồi mà họ vẫn không tăng
mức lương lên thì lúc đấy tôi chọn nghỉ
Tôi cảm thấy là Đạt được tương nối đủ
rồi Nghĩa phải để nghĩa tôi cố gắng khi
mà đến cái ngưỡng một cái giới ranh giới
nào đó tôi cảm thấy là Ok mình mình hài
lòng với cái hiện tại rồi mình cố hết
hết sức rồi mà vẫn không đạt được như ý
thì mình buông thôi Nói chung là mình
phải biết buông đúng lúc nhưng mình cũng
phải biết phần đấu đến để mà buông Chứ
nhiều người tôi thấy là đa số là chưa
bắt đầu đã buông rồi chưa bắt đầu đã
trùn chân rồi thì tự mình giới hạn khả
năng của bản thân thôi chứ chẳng ai làm
điều đấy cả đặc biệt là Thời đại bây giờ
là thời đại cạnh tranh rất nhiều nữa
không phải người với người nữa Ai với
người luôn rất nhiều cái rất rất nhiều
cái cạnh tranh đúng không ạ giới trẻ
cạnh tranh với với nhau thậm chí giới
trẻ cạnh tranh với cả người già Tức là
sao bây giờ rất nhiều ông lão làng bây
giờ cũng bị đuổi việc thì mấy ông đấy mà
Mấy ông ấy chỉ cần giảm đi cái mức thu
nhập của họ họ chấp nhận mức thu nhập
thấp hơn một tí là coi như họ cũng kiếm
được việc và mấy ông Junio cũng lướt đấy
thế nên là cạnh tranh nó rất là khó khăn
hơn rất nhiều đấy là trong mỗi ngành
ngành này tôi không biết ngành khác thế
nào nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi
nghĩ là quá nửa vẫn đang rất là mơ hồ
đang tự đang gọi là tự mình kìm hãm mình
nghĩa là tự tự họ đã thua họ về ý chí
rồi còn mấy ông chỉ việc thắng bản thân
ông ý chí là mấy ông đã ăn đứt được bọn
họ để mấy ông vươn lên rồi tôi đấy là
tôi nghĩ là như thế chứ còn về năng lực
mỗi người đng như là tôi thấy năng lực
mỗi người khác nhau Tôi không đánh giá
được Nhưng mà ví dụ Giả sử
đấy mấy ông dám uply mà họ không dám thì
mấy ông ít nhất là mấy ông đã thắng được
những cái ông không dám apply rồi đúng
không
làm Final Project bằng
đâu ổn mấy ông ạ Ờ cái này chắc là để
người khác trả lời cho mấy ông đương
nhiên là tôi thấy Java nó chuyên về kiểu
lý thuyết các thứ thứ chắc là phải Xẽ
xem một cái khóa học miễn phí ở trên
mạng và tài liệu nữa phải đọc rất nhiều
tài
trưng bạn bắt đầu cảm thấy tự tin vì bạn
bè hả B bắt đầu cảm thấy T tự ti hay tự
tin vì bạn bạn bè có việc hết rồi hối
hận khi chọn học 5 năm hay vì học 4
năm có cái cái việc là học học nhiều năm
với việc ra trường sớm Ý tôi là người ra
trườngng sớm tôi thấy là cái nào cũng có
ưu và nhược thôi Tôi không cảm thấy là
việc là mình mình à may mắn hơn những
cái Khi mà mình
à mình ra trường sớm hơn các bạn à Kiểu
dạ dạng là cũng có lợi Đấy là điểm Lợi
thôi Nếu tôi nhìn thấy góc tích cực là
nó cũng là điểm Lợi thời gian đầu là tôi
kiếm được việc trước các thứ các thứ
nhưng mà về về sau này ví dụ ngay bây
giờ là thuật tán tôi yếu cái kiến thức
nền của tôi bây giờ tôi phải tự bổ suung
thêm những cái kiến thức trên trường đấy
nó vẫn có cái ý nghĩa vô hình rất nhiều
không phải nỗi lý thuyết bởi vì là lý
thuyết thì mình có thể quên nhưng mà
mình thể học lại mình biết được nguồn
hay mọi thứ Học lại từ đâu vân vân cả là
học tôi nghĩ học đại học nói chung đôi
khi ở bây giờ nó vẫn rèn cho mình về cái
kỷ luật hay rất nhiều cái khác
nữa chứ không phải là ra trường đời rồi
đợi trường đời nó rẻn bởi vì nhiều công
ty họ không họ không thời gian để đào
tạo rèn cho mấy ông mấy ông mấy cái cái
đấy đấy thế nên là tôi thấy việc ra
trường sớm hay muộn thậm chí thậm chí
nhá Hôm trước có một cái chủ đề rất là
hay Có người hỏi là Ờ em đi nghĩa vụ 2
năm sau rồi bây giờ em về em đi bây giờ
em mới đi về thì bây giờ em có nên ghi
cái đấy vào trong civ không thì rõ ràng
là đặc biệt về cái ngành này khi mà 2
năm bạn không đổ động máy tính giả sử
Không được động vào đấy thì nó sẽ bị
giảm kiến thức kiểu quên đi kiến thức
khá nhiều đúng không ạ nhưng mà tôi cảm
thấy là nên ghi vào trong CV cái đấy vì
thứ nhất là mình tự hàm về điều đấy thứ
hai là nó rèn cho mình cái sự kỷ luật mà
kiểu nói chung là mình kỷ luật và cái ý
chí nó hơn rất nhiều cái người đấy có
thể là họ bắt đầu khởi đầu sau khởi đầu
muộn các thứ họ bị quên kiến thức đi họ
còn phải học lại nhưng
mà tôi tin là những cái người đấy họ có
cái ý chí mạnh mẽ kiên cường hơn nhiều
à Tôi kể mấy ông ở vược là tôi từng khoe
mấy ông là tôi đi phỏng vấn gần như là
là thứ nhất là người quen giới thiệu nên
Thành A cũng cũng chẳng phải trả lời mấy
là một cũng như là khi tôi phỏng vấn tôi
không bị hỏi mấy câu về thuật toán hay
là về code mấy không chứ bị hỏi có khi
tôi không ngồi đây ngồi chia xem mấy ông
khi tôi đang đi thất nghiệp thôi Bởi vì
sao Bởi vì khi mà khi mà phóng vấn ấy
người ta thứ nhất là người ta đến ở gần
đây tôi được đi phỏng vấn ở bên fvt để
mà đi dạy nói người ta khi mà nghe qua
về kiểu kinh nghiệm kinh nghiệm ở phần
xong rồi nghe qua về kiểu cách tôi nói
chuyện hay vân vân họ muốn tuyển tôi rồi
bởi vì bởi vì họ cảm thấy là đây thứ
nhất là đây không phải thằng chỉ biết
nói
à thứ hai đó là chị là cái họ đang biết
được là người này phù hợp kiểu gọi là
tâm huyết với công việc cũng như
là có thể nói và làm được người này kể
cả cho dù họ chưa biết làm họ sẽ biết
gọi là biết cách để mà chủ động trong
công việc để làm được đấy rất có tâm
kiểu như thế đấy tôi Tôi cảm thấy tôi tự
đánh giá được như thế đó là họ tuyển Tôi
không phải vì năng lực của tôi hiện tại
có thể năng lực của tôi hiện tại tôi
không phải tôi không phải con nhà người
ta mà tôi không giỏi Tho toán n vẫn Tôi
có rất nhiều cái trong câu hỏi tôi có
thể trả lời tôi chưa làm tôi chưa biết
nhưng mà họ tuyển họ tuyển là chủ yếu
vẫn là tuyệt con người họ cảm thấy là có
thể làm việc được với con người này khi
mà có vấn đề gì họ Cái người này sẽ chủ
động trong công việc ấy để làm ra được
việc đấy ví dụ điển hình nhất nhé tôi
chia sẻ Thật là kiểu hôm qua tôi qua bên
fvt để mà lại ngồi trao đổi việc là qua
bên đấy Dậy ấ thì bên đấy như mấy ông
đang có thể mấy ông tìm hiểu rồi m ông
sẽ biết bên đấy không dễ pp nhưng tôi
tôi có nói với anh đấy và tôi khẳng định
là kiểu là em chuyên ề pp bây giờ bảo em
nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác thì em vẫn nhảy
được để em học nhưng mà để bảo để em dạy
cái đấy thì bởi em chưa có nhiều kinh
nghiệm về cái đấy chưa trải nghiệm thực
tế về cái ngôn ngữ đấy thì chắc rằ làem
không tự tin và và nhân viên hỏi à nh
Sinh viên hỏi thì thì sẽ không Tôi không
dạy Cao đẳng tôi dạy FPT academy là kiểu
Nó là kiểu Học Viện Dạy ngắn hạn dạy
nghề hơn tôi cảm thấy nó phù hợp hơn vởi
vì tôi đã từng Thực ra tôi đ từng dạy
Cao đẳng đấy rồi và tôi cũng dạy nghề
kiểu đấy rồi nhưng mà bây giờ tôi đang
dạy tôi đang làm full time ở công ty này
tôi không thể dạy Cao đẳng được tôi cù
nắm sang đấy chỉ pass time trước đã đấy
Thì đại khái thì bên đấy không có dạy
fpp đúng không ạ Thì bởi vì họ cũng
không đảm bảo cái đầu da bởi vì các các
nguồn công việc có thể đảm bảo đồ ra ở
bên fd giờ chủ yếu là java hay là ngôn
ngữ khác
à Thì tôi tôi bảo với họ là em tự tin là
em làm được và em Đấy thấy mạnh của em
à Có cứ cứ để đầu tiên là em sẽ kiểu dạy
có thể không phải ngôn ngữ chung mà chỉ
là kiểu lập trình cơ bản ở bên này có
cái khóa lập trình cơ bản it cái gì gì
đó không nhớ fenal cái gì gì đó là code
dạy kiểu mấy cái kiến thức cơ bản lập
trình thì cứ để em học thử qua một cái
khóa đấy Xong rồi em thử dạy lại mấy cái
buổi khóa đấy thì mọi người xem em cách
dạy em phù hợp với bên mình không đã sau
đó thì em sẽ soạn gáo án để dạy về
P và em sẽ đảm bảo đầu ra cho bên mình
đấy Nói thế xong thì nó là một cái khác
mình đang thấy bí là theo kiểu là bên
đấy không dạy pp và mình sẽ phải theo
format bên đấy thì tôi nói là kiểu đấy
thì em em dậy theo cái thế mạnh của em
và em nghĩ là khi mà sinh và nó là một
cái kiểu gọi nhỉ ạ nó thêm một cái lựa
chọn mới cho sinh viên để sinh viên Giả
sử thích pp thì họ sẽ sang bên mình để
học thay vì học ở trung tâm khác vì bên
mình không dậy đúng không ạ Đấy mình Hãy
tự tin vào thế mạnh của mình đấy các thứ
thứ vân vân lên và mình thể hiện là được
là mình có đảm bảo ha mọi thứ như thế
thì ai chẳng hài hòng không và đặc biệt
là và b bên đấy cũng
C không Đương nhiên là tôi không phải
khoe không phải quảng cáo bên đấy vân
vân Nhưng mà đang nói là cái hồi mà tôi
phỏng vấn thì tôi cảm thấy là ít nhất là
các thầy phỏng vấn tôi thì tôi cảm thấy
là họ có cùng chí hướng với mình hoặc cá
ra họ nói thế đó là chẻ là họ vì sinh
viên họ ít nhất là họ nói thế không biết
là họ thực sự khi dạy học hay các thứ
như nào n họ bảo là đúng là mọi thứ là
vì sinh viên Nghĩa là cũng chỉ muốn sinh
viên học được hài lòng với nhà trường
hài lòng với kiểu chương trình học tập
và và ra ngoài làm được việc kiếm được
việc làm hỗ trợ hết sức cho sinh viên
thì sinh viên có thể học xong có thể đi
làm được đấy thì rất là phù hợp với cái
định hướng đi dạy của tôi nên tôi mới
kiểu muốn muốn như
thế ca nói thật là tôi từng đi dạy kiểu
kia tôi phòn tôi đã từng được mời làm
trưởng phòng đào tạo Hà noi ở một một
công ty Thực ra tôi không nhớ TH công ty
đấy nhưng mà ở bên Cầu
Giấy và Nói chung cũng được mời đ dạy ở
một vài trường rồi Vài trường đấy nó bé
bé nên là cũng cần giáo viên và cũng có
biết tôi từng đi dạy các thứ thứ rồi
nhưng là tôi cảm thấy là tạ nhờ Ờ tự
nhiên lại đi bị khoe mẽ đi xa vấn đề qua
rồi nhưng mà đại khái thì tôi quay
lại Tóm tắt lại C tôi vừa nói thì nó là
chỉ là mình biết được à thế mạnh của
mình năng lực của mình Mình tự tin với
nó thì chắc chắn là tôi nghĩ là sẽ qua
được phòng vấn phòng phòng vấn khá dễ
dàng thôi đúng không Nói chuyện thế thì
kiểu ai ai cũng cảm thấy là kiểu mình
không phải nói mồm đúng không
abt academy mà
tôi tôi nhớ FBT có ba cái nó là đại học
này cao đẳng này và kiểu academy học
viện giống kiểu cái trường nghề nó chỉ
có khóa học ngắn hạn thôi Kiểu 2 3 tháng
hay 6 tháng gì
anh nhỉ Tôi nhớ là hình như là không thì
phải Tôi không chắc lắm m cái này tôi
không kểu người bên đấy T không rõ chưa
phải người bên
làm được khoảng 7 tháng xong nghỉ
Ờ đúng rồi bây giờ Thời v cạnh tranh mà
ờ nế chính mấy ông ở đây còn đang đối đá
nhau chứ đừng nói người đu Đáng Người
ngoài tôi khuyên mấy ông thấy Xong tôi
với hy vọng là mấy ông gọi là gọi như tự
tin hơn để mà có thể ít nhất là tự tin
Tôi bảo rồi thực ra là có nhiều người là
thua bản thân mình ngay từ vòng bui xe
rồi Chưa cần phải đi kiểu dạng là đi đấu
tranh với ai đâu ạ Mấy ông thắng bản
thân mấy ông đi đã Xong rồi ra ngoài đồ
tranh mới có thể cạnh tranh đ người khác
tôi nhiều thấy nhiều ông thua bản thân
mình lắm
sinh viên tôi có mà nên tôi hiểu
nào gọi là tốt với anh
ờ Thực ra là cũng không cần phải tự tạo
lực bản thân mình quá đâu đừng có biểu
ngựa non hu đá quá Thực ra là là như nào
Theo tôi ấy Ừ tôi thường anh nói mấy ông
là cái công việc này nó nó để mà lâu dài
và gọi nh Tôi thường ha ví mấy ông là
cái này cái việc đi làm này không khác
gì yêu đương đúng không ạ thứ nhất là
bạn cũng nên chung thủy Một công việc
thôi một người thôi đấy
Ờ bạn Dồn hết tâm huyết vào cho người
đấy bạn à hãy thể hiện những cái những
cái tinh tế những cái chi tiết nhỏ mình
cảm thấy là nên làm thì mình nên nên làm
mình đừng có ngại ngần gì cả Mình có
đừng có mình có mình có gì mình cứ thể
hiện hết ra mình cũng không Mình cũng
không nên kiểu kiểu dạng là kiểu sống
sống giả kiểu mình không nên giả tạo
mình không nên kiểu à đương nhiên giả
tạo Chắc là tùy tùy môi trường bạn vẫn
thể giả tạo với đồng nghiệp nhưng tôi đ
Nói với sếp cơ sếp vẫn có thể biết hết
kiểu gì chẳng lộ ra nếu bạn chém gió các
thứ thứ bạn
à Nói chung là đánh bóng bản thân các
thứ thứ quá kiểu gì chẳng về sao chẳng
lò ra đúng không nên là nên là sống thật
và và nếu mà cái môi trường làm việc đấy
phù hợp nếu người yêu đấy phù hợp thì nó
sẽ rất là lâu dài nó sẽ khiến một môi
trường à một môi trường tốt một công
việc tốt một mối quan hệ tốt là là là
kiểu khiến nó cả hai cùng thoải mái và
cùng cùng tốt hơn cùng tốt lên
đấy
à đừng có nghĩ về việc là mình đang thực
tập nên mình phải thế nào Kể cả lúc đi
làm thì thì cũng nên như thế luôn
đấy theo tôi là như
mình phải phô mình phải phô diễn hay
mình phải mình phải giải trừng hay gì đó
Cứ thoải mái thôi theo tôi quan điểm về
mọi mối quan hệ nó cũng thế mình thoải
mái người khác cũng sẽ thoải
mái giữa da và bend thì cái nào khó h
hơn ạ
Ừ đép Làm bây giờ Bây giờ Bây giờ mấy
ông để ý thì nó cũng sẽ rõ thôi Nó là
kiểu
da nhưng mà có nhiều anh em lập trình
đúng không ạ thì theo tôi thì da lương
thường nó vẫn sẽ cao hơn và nó khó hơn
khó hơn ở đây là không phải khó hơn
trong công việc Cái đấy là nhìn khi mà
bạn đến cái cái trình độ đấy thì chắc là
nó cũng tàng tàng nhìn người khác nhìn
bạn bạn trộng nhàn dừng ba cũng thế
nhưng mà nhưng mà để lên cái trình độ
đấy cũng như là
để thường là công ty tuyển thì vẫn sẽ
cần nhiều năm kinh
nghiệm không phải ph sơ các thứ thứ Nên
là theo tôi thì da nó sẽ gọi là là việc
sau này Đấy là theo quan điểm của tôi là
nếu mà muốn từ dep lên ba da hay ba còn
nếu mà ông Ngay từ đầu ông nhảy vào da
thì nó lại trường hợp khác
Ờ nhưng mà lúc đầu mà nhảy vào da ấ thì
theo tôi ông nên là dân kinh tế chứ
không phải dân kỹ thuật còn kỹ thuật thì
vẫn là nên làm đp trước larel và sping
boot Anh thấy cái nào hiện tại sẽ kếm
việc hơn ạ Ông mà làm được cả hai thì
quá ngon luôn còn nếu Giả sử ông chưa
biết chọn cái gì thì ông cứ làm thử một
cái mà ông thấy thích đã Ông không cần
quan tâm nó là công nghệ gì bởi vì ông
phải thích thì ông mới làm được chứ bây
giờ ông cứ theo người ta thôi làm cái
thứ ông không thích thì ông không làm
được tới ny đến trốn thì ông chẳng kiếm
được việc Uầy Hôm nay tự nhiên tôi Tư
vấn cái này mượt phết rõ ràng khối trước
thì tôi còn phải ngồi
nghĩ anh codt mà dùng m có ổn không Anh
thực ra là ông dùng từ mà thì giống kiểu
ông không chưa giống má và cũng giống
tôi hồi trước tôi nghĩ thế m mar bây giờ
đúng là rất là tối ưu cho kiểu việc code
các thứ thậm chí là gần đây Tôi định
kiểu tôi định mua máy Windows để mà kiểu
đi dậy và vẫn sẽ có code một tí nữa thì
anh em đều gà kìa em chuyển qua m rồi em
không thấy ma dùng thích à em muốn quay
lại Windows à Thì ông sẽ hiểu được là
mọi ngườ mọi người kiểu bây giờ bị kiểu
một khi sang m code thì không quay trở
lại win
Ờ nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ nghĩa là m Nói
chung là tiện với việc code B giờ thấy
mọi thứ ổn phết à mượt hơn khá nhiều ổn
định nữa đấy còn nhưng mà để Nếu giả sử
mấy ông vẫn muốn ngồi chơi game vẫn muốn
dùng các thứ thứ thì tôi ví dụ tôi sắp
mua máy tôi vẫn sẽ cài song song cả
Windows cả Linux tôi sẽ đị kiểu sử dụng
cả hệ hệ điều hành linus ubert nữa vì
cái bên đấy mới gọi là chuyên về code
kiểu Tôi nhớ là anh leader tôi có nói đó
là gần như mọi phần mềm hoặc là tất cả
phần mềm luôn ấy đó tất cả phần mềm mà
hỗ trợ cho code
ấy đều s đều làm cho linus hoặc UP2
trước bởi vì cái hệ điều hành đấy Kiểu
sinh ra dành cho anh em dep nên anh em
dep sẽ luôn làm cho cái đấy trước xong
rồi mới kểu làm sang hệ điều hành khác
đấy thế nên là à Tôi sẽ dùng over linus
để mà ngồi code và Windows để mà có thể
chơi game hoặc là Dạy học các thứ thứ
bởi vì Dạy học dạy bằng Windows thì sinh
viên n cảm thấy quen thuộc chứ Bây giờ
mình lôi máy m ra dạy thì nhiều bạn đang
dùng win chẳng hiểu mình đang thao tác
gì đúng không
ạ u may tâm sự cần 1 tiếng
rưỡi thôi bảo vừa nãy mấy ông xem này
cho mấy ông xem nha hay
cực Anh p
đ có giật mình không để lấy kinh nghiệm
mà không hợp với sếp thì nên quýt hay
thay đổi để thích nghi với sếp ạ địt mẹ
đã làm không lương rồi mà còn không hợp
với sếp thì cút thôi chứ còn gì nữa Đã
đi làm không lương là để lấy kinh nghiệm
mà mày xếp còn không cho được mình kinh
nghiệm nữa thì lại đi làm để làm gì rèn
luyện bản thân
à Đi làm nó chỉ có hai cái hai cái mục
tiêu thôi của tất cả mọi người đi làm
sau này ông làm chủ hay sau này ông làm
tớ đi chắc nữa thì ông nhớ trong đầu chỉ
có hai người ta đi làm chỉ có hai mục
tiêu thôi Một là vì tiền đấy là 99 ph là
mọi người đi làm vì tiền và cái thứ hai
ấ đấy là về vì một cái Lý tưởng nào đó
mà Lý Tưởng này thì thường là ông sếp
đặt ra chứ còn ai đặt ra nữa có đúng
không m mà đi làm đây tiền cũng không có
lý tưởng cũng không Thế đến đấy để làm
Zombie để nhìn nhau để kiểu Mẹ kiểu Hey
Hello How are you today
à
anh anh pp rất phũ kiểu rất hay nói
chuyện kiểu nh rội cm nước vào mặt đúng
không ạ Ờ thức ra là nghe cái vừa rồi
Tôi vừa mới lớt cái tiktok này và cũng
lại nhớ lại
cái anh anh Minh mom Hôm trước có khuyên
tôi à có kể tôi về cái quan điểm anh đấy
về khi tìm công việc thì anh ấy cũng bởi
vì thực ra là anh ấy lên ngưỡng kiểu
senio Master rồi nên thành ra là cái
việc anh ấy đi tìm công việc nghĩa anh
chọn công việc chứ không phải công việc
chọn anh nữa ngĩ trị anh ấ thoải mái
hoàn toàn lự quyết định được trong các
thứ nhưng mà theo tôi cũng thế theo tôi
là thực ra ngay từ lúc đầu tôi đi đi tìm
việc thì tôi vẫn cảm thấy tôi làm chủ
chủ động bởi vì rõ rng mình đi tìm việc
mình ứng tuyển vào công việc rất nhiều
người bây giờ khai niệm đi xin việc ngay
từ lúc đầu mình cứ cứ bị bị cứ khiến
mình ở thế Bị động và mình cứ biến mình
thành Thế gọi là yếu hơn ấy nên là mấy
ông thay đổi dần V quan điểm đấy tốt
à thì cái việc khi mà đi tìm công việc
thì anh ấy bảo là Dựa theo ba ý tố một
là về mức lương mức lương cực kỳ hấp dẫn
thì thôi mình có thể xem xét à Nhưng mà
cái mức lương sẽ là cái xem xét cuối
cùng anh đấy bởi một phần là bởi vì anh
đấy Tuy là mang tiếng cũng có gia đình
rồi nhưng mà gọi nhở cũng gọi nhở à cũng
không thể rơi vào cái mức lương kiểu cực
K thấp nữa không thể chấp nhận được cũng
không
thể kiểu Chắc anh ấy cùng lý tưởng với
tôi là ch mình sống không hẳn là mọi thứ
bị tiền th thành ra là kiểu gọi là có
tiền thì mình vẫn sống được mình kiếm
được 10 triệu thì mình sống kiểu 10
triệu mình kiếm được 20 triệu mình sống
kiểu 20 triệu mình không phải khá chạy
đùa Nếu giả sử mà kiếm nội thấp quá thôi
Đương nhiên mình cũng phải xem xét Nếu
giả sử mình sống ở thành phố thì đương
nhiên là đúng có nhiều cái nó phải khó
chi tiêu hơn à nhưng là đấy là theo quan
điểm của tôi nhá
À và quan điểm của anh ấy nữa và cái thứ
hai đó là liên quan đến sếp và môi
trường làm việc nghĩa là sếp và đồng
nghiệp các thứ Môi trường đấy có kiểu
dạng thân thiện Thoải mái để mình cơ hội
phát triển các thứ thứ không Vân Vân rất
nhiều yếu tố trong đấy nữa Cái này hơi
khó để mà lúc đầu ông có thể đánh giá
được nhưng ông thể đánh giá qua người
phỏng vấn cũng như là thậm chí là được
nói chuyện với sế thì rất là tốt thể
biết được qua cái tính cách hay mọi thứ
của người đấy hôm trước tôi cũng đọc một
cái bài ở trên J2 team community về kiểu
những cái à lời khuyên về phỏng vấn các
thứ mấy ông có thể lên nhóm để mà tìm
đọc chắc là lần này tôi sẽ không để link
mấy ông nữa Để mấy ông chủ động việc tìm
mọi thứ vậ trên đấy thực ạ Có rất nhiều
bài hay không phải mỗi cái bài đấy
à còn Nếu mà Mấy ông xem cái này ở ở mấy
cái tuần sau mấy ông mới xem được thì
mấy ông phải biết từ khóa mấy ông tra
nhá chắc là mấy ông sẽ biết được cách
tra thôi đấy
ờ và cái cuối cùng anh ấy nói đó là về
sản phẩm cái sản phẩm này th ra như tôi
đã nói thì bởi vì anh ấy đến cái ngưỡng
mà anh đấy đi làm quan tâm đến Kiểu cái
các bạn nhở cái mục tiêu đầu xa rồi còn
mấy ông bây giờ mấy ông vẫn còn đi tìm
việc thì th ra mấy ông chưa cần quan tâm
này nhưng là Nếu giả sử là mấy ông có
quan tâm đến cả sản phẩm công ty xem là
công ty định hướng công ty làm sản phẩm
nó như nào nó thực tế thiết thực nó có
thể ngon lành nó có thể tiến xa được
không vân vân vân chứ Giả sử
ông gọi là cố lắm để xin vào một công ty
rồi sản phẩm rất Lom rom vớ vẩn xong rồi
Vài tháng kh công ty phá sản thì ông đi
tìm việc thì nó lại cũng hơi bị buồn
cười đúng không ạ Đấy thì
Anh ấy làm đã thế anh còn muốn làm sản
phẩm đấy sản phẩm Đấy nó phải rất là
Tiếm năng là the kiểu à Nó thể đấy nó có
thể gọi gọi khái niệm scale À nghĩa là
có thể phình to ra có thể phát triển
bùng nổ các thứ lớn mạnh hơn rất nhiều
thể có thể nhân 3 nhân 4
à Sau này đúng không ạ phn bây giờ sản
phẩm Nói chung về công nghệ nó phải như
thế còn nếu mà nó kiểu cứ cứ kiểu dậm
chân tại chỗ ấy thì chắc chắn là sản
phẩm đấy nó chuẩn bị chết rồi sản phẩm
chuẩn bị thất bại rồi vì đối thủ nó tạo
cái tương tự ông chết ngay Hoặc là ông
tự chết bởi vì ông ông không phát triển
nó là liên quan đến gì chết học à Ông
chỉ có lùi hoặc tiến thôi ông dẫn chân
thực ra là ông đang lùi rồi sẽ ngày ông
tự tự kiểu gọi là quy luật tự nhiên là
tự bị bài trừ thôi
à dùng từ bà chứng đ t bị loại bỏ bị
sang lọc à Kiểu kiểu
trước em phỏng vấn à Đúng rồi đạp Hải
đúng rồi cảm ơn ạ
À đấy nghĩa chứng tỏ có người lắng nghe
mình kìa định mãi tôi cứ tưởng nãy giờ
mấy ông không
nghe tôi chủ yếu Tôi vẫn đang chia sẻ
góc nhì nhìn tôi mà nghĩ âm Chỉ là không
Cái này không phải ai nghe được nhưng mà
tôi cảm thấy là
à rất rất nhiều cái tôi cảm thấy là
nhiều người ngại
nói nhiều người ngại nói ra quan điểm
của mình ấy đấy nó hơi bị dở là như thế
m hoàn toàn thể mạnh nói ra quan điểm
của mình thì chúng ta còn còn mới có cái
mà nói chuyện đúng không ạ Giả sử là ai
cũng im lặng ai cũng giữ cái quan điểm
của mình thì thì nó hơi giờ đúng không
ạ tự nhiên tôi nhớ cái annh hài Gần đây
tôi đọc ô kiểu nó hơi thô tục một tí nhớ
cái ảnh này rồi Kiểu một người nhắn
trong nhóm chat kiểu hỏi ý kiến mọi
người xong rồi Kiểu tất cả mọi người đã
xem xong rồi
ờ
ờ tất cả mọi người đã xem X với kiểu ông
ấy nhắn thêm người nữa Mọi người ơi
Messenger chưa có chế độ là đọp được
được suy nghĩ mọi người đâu ạ nên mọi
người Mở con mẹ cái môm lên được không
làm chư mấy ông nên chia sẻ quan điểm
nói nói là những suy nghĩ mọi thứ bản
thân mình thì có cái mà nói chuyện đúng
không
trước mặt m ông như vậy Ở ngoài T ở
ngoài đời thì tôi cũng C khi mở ra đó Mở
chế độ trá trâu thì tôi cũng trá trâu
lắm Tôi cũng văng các thứ các thứ nhưng
mà văng ở đây văng Vẫn kiểu nh gọi là
văng tục gọi kiểu chơi thề có chời thề
vui vui thì có không có nỗi chửi gắt
đâu vui mà tôi còn phải học cách chửi
sao cho nghe nó kiểu vui vui tí chứ chưa
kiểu chửi ch
kểu nghe khó nghe thì nó hơi
quá
tí không lên quan cơ mà hôm trước em
phỏng vấn Anh ấy hỏi Index em không biết
anh ấy cười khẩy em ngại quá anh ạ Anh
có thể nói về cách đánh Index trong DB
không ạ Anh có dạy cái playlist về Index
ấy nhưng mà Đúng là đúng là nó cũng kiến
thức hồi đấy anh cũng không nói lý
thuyết nhiều lắm nhưng mà Index th về cơ
bản thì code là em chỉ cần đơn giản việc
tạo Index trên những cái cột mà Em
thường hay kiểu truy vấn kiểu que trên
nó nhiều không cần nhất thế là Chu vắn
theo kiểu là select chỉ cần nó là update
hoặc Delete phải que trên mấy cái cột mà
thường hay thường hay kiểu kiểu sử dụng
nó thì thường qu nó thì em nên đánh trên
mấy cột đấy K việc là mấy cái cột đấy nó
nói chung là em xem cái video đấy thì
anh sẽ nói cụ thể chi tiết hơn trong cái
playlist SQL
trong pp store mà thầy dùng được không ạ
Ờ tôi nhớ tôi Tôi không nhớ giờ Gần đây
tôi đã chia sẻ mấy ông chưa Nhưng mà tôi
tôi cho mấy ông xem lại nhá Để tôi cảm
thấy là tôi cảm thấy là gần đây tôi cà
tôi càng ít quan tâm về mấy cái blin này
khá nhiều rồi Chắc là thứ nh nh là tôi
dùng C pilot này mấy ông cần quan tâm ai
code các thứ thứ hai là g tool box này
để mà biết được là xem lịch sử git này
và xem được là cái dòng đấy ông nào ngồi
code để pl ông đấy này hoặc play bản
thân thì né ra đấy và larel query để gợi
ý về kiểu mấy cái truy vấn larel và cũng
như là nó gợi ý luôn cả database như thế
nhưng mấy cũng phải kết nối cả database
nữa thì nó gợi ý chuẩn hơn nhá n cả cái
này nữa Cái này rất là ngon Anh Tuấn gợi
ý này cái này là nó gợi ý rất nhiều cái
liên quan đến kiểu code đang có vấn đề
có vấn đề nói chung là thế vậy nó sẽ rất
rất nhiều ông cài xong ông mới biết và
thê là qua Time để ông đo ông code kiểu
các thứ thứ nho Đấy đấy là những cái mà
tôi cà còn những cái dưới thì mấy ông
đọc mà hiểu thì m Ông mở lên còn không
thì thôi Thế thôi C pilot mất phí không
à chuẩn là có nhưng mấy ông có meu hay
là mấy ông kiếm được meu Kiểu mua onl
Vân Vân rất nhiều cách tôi thì tôi cũng
kiếm được meu tôi đang dùng Mau cũ gần
đây tôi học lên Thông rồi còn sau thì
chắc là tôi phải mua m
đu Còn không thì có hình như là sếp tôi
gần đây cũng có chia sẻ cái cái ai miễn
phí cũng gợ ý nó nó có vẻ không mạnh
bằng C pilot nhưng mà nó gợi ý cũng
tương đối sếp cũng bảo khá hài lòng vấn
đề đấy về sếp kiểu mang tiếng Sếp tôi
không muốn trả tiền nhưng mà À không
muốn dùng crack không muốn dùng
kiểu mua kiểu edu kiểu kia nhưng mà sếp
tội cũng không muốn trả
index thì sao ạ bản thân tôi làm việc
với in nhiều nhưng mà tôi không nhớ và
cũng chưa tìm hiểu về mấy cái đấy luôn
ấy Tôi nghĩ về sau tôi vẫn sẽ tìm hiểu
thôi Nhưng mà chị là nếu mà đối với kiến
thức của anh em de Nói chung thì là chỉ
cần biết đánh đấy là quá đủ rồi chứ
không quan tâm với việc xấu xa hơn Đế
Thế về mấy cái đấy chắc là nó không phải
việc của anh em de mà anh của anh em làm
về
ờ trường rất là vô danh và tôi không thể
quảng cáo trường ấy được vì tôi thấy
trường đấy Ơ gọi như
nà tôi sẽ không bình luận gì về trường
Hồi trước tôi học ở Học viện Công nghệ
thông tin Bách hoa bk Còn bây giờ thì nó
là học viện thông tin là học viện gì Học
Viện B hay có thử thử
Ờ nói chung là trên Facebook tôi thực ra
có toàn bộ những thông tin mà nếu M mấy
ông thắc mắc Thực ra cũng chẳng cần phải
tìm hiểu đâu nói chung Tôi phải con nhà
người ta đâu mà Mấy ông tìm hiểu nó nó
chỉ là gọi là
à Nó chẳng có gì để tìm hiểu
ngại về tiêu cực quá mất động lực học
tiếp
á ông phải xem cái video hôm trước tôi
livestream chim khi mà Anh p p à Hai anh
độ ấy hai anh bom men ấy Đúng rồi hình
như anh bom men anh chửi xối xả những
cái ông mà kiểu ờ đúng kiểu này lại thêm
một rội gáo nước lạnh về khái niệm mà
kiểu Mấy ông không học tiếp thì mấy ông
Định làm gì bây giờ đấy các thử thử thì
mấy ông sẽ tỉnh ra thôi đôi khi khái
niệm là mình mình biết được điều đấy
nhưng người khác phải chửi vào mặt mình
ấy phải dùng từ chửi đấy Kiểu Thế thì tự
nhiên mình mới ngộ ra được nó cũng hay m
không Đừng có ng nghe mấy kiểu dạng là
lôi hay là kiểu nghe gì à Podcast để mà
là healing cái thứ thứ nữa m nghe chửi
đi thật tôi sống tôi sinh ra lớn lên
trong những câu chửi nó hơi bị áp lực
nhưng cũng có rất nhiều cái thứ cũng
không tốt nhưng mà cái cái tôi cảm thấy
có một tí tác dụng tốt đó là thứ nhất là
tôi chẳng ng nghe Chử nữa thứ hai tôi
vẫn có cái tôi của tôi nhá vẫn bị tự ái
nhá Tôi không ngại gì nữa và tôi tôi gọi
là nhở tôi cũng không ngại khó không
ngại nhiều cái nữa cái tôi tôi cũng gọi
nhở bây giờ nó cũng hạ thấp hơn rồi Kiểu
thế chứ Bây giờ tôi thường hay có câu
đấy Cuộc sống quá ng ngắn ngủi cho ngại
ngùng mấy ông đừng có ngại gì cả thích
thì làm không thích thì không làm đừng
có ngại phải dứt khoát lên
toán không ạ Không thầy như tôi đã nói
thật ra tùy C công ty và mấy ông thể
hiện nếu mà Mấy ông không giỏi cái đấy
thì mấy ông cứ khoe ra còn mấy ông không
giỏi thì mấy ông phải làm chủ cái cuộc
phỏng vấn đấy hướng nó sang cái khác mấy
ông có thể thừa nhận lúc đầu là mấy ông
không giỏi về thật tán không sao cả miễn
là mấy ông có tư duy còn Nếu giả sử Mấy
ông không có tư duy thì hơi khó ở theo
anh này
thật tư duy Du ở đây là thế nào là tư
duy chỉ chỉ kiểu bạn gặp một cái bài
toán bạn một là bạn biết cách làm luôn
bạn nghĩ ở phương pháp làm bạn kiểu
người hiểu nhanh học nhanh hai là bạn
cũng là một người
kiểu chịu khó mình m Tìm cách giải đáp
các th thứ bạn thể hiện cái tố chất bản
thân mình nói chung là mấy ông đi phỏng
vấn là để người ta hiểu hơn V mấy ông mà
Mấy ông phải phải cho họ được thấy được
thế mạnh của mình Thức ra cũng không hẳn
cũng đừng ngại chỉ cho họ biết được yếu
điểm của mình là gì Đừng có kiểu đừng có
ngại Đừng có giấu vài cái cũng thừa nhận
thẳng thôi không thì ông phỏng vấn được
thì ông vẫn bị loại lúc mà làm thực tập
thôi mà
À nói chung là tôi nghĩ là ngành này
thì ai cũng học được nhưng mà không phải
ai cũng theo được
à m ông phải dần dần phải tự hiểu được
là mình có phù hợp hay không một khi mấy
mà Mấy ông cảm thấy phù hợp thì mấy ông
phải thể hiện được chứng chứng minh được
cho mọi người thấy được là mình phù hợp
Còn nếu mà ông không chứng minh được thì
tôi không nghĩ là chắc ông phù hợp
HR không phỏng vấn nhé Ừ hồi trước là
tôi tôi nhớ Tôi cũng bị hỏi hai câu về
thật toán nhưng mà tôi trả lời một câu
một câu thì tôi gọi nhở không nhớ tôi
trả lời như nào Nhưng đại khái là tôi
nhớ tôi chỉ trả lời một câu sau đó về
sau là tôi kể về con người tôi công việc
hay mọi thứ hơn là những dự án Tôi từng
làm hơn những cái pet Project Tôi từng
làm là Sau đó họ chẳng hỏi nữa và họ
Tuyền thẳng
À Uy hôm nay tâm sự được khá nhiều rồi
th Xem phép là để buổi sau tâm sự tiếp V
sao sẽ có nhiều cái ở đây để cho mấy ông
tôi định tâm sự khá nhiều đấy mấy ông có
câu mấy ông có câu hỏi hay tâm sự gì mấy
ông cứ hỏi đây nha câu này Hôm trước tôi
trả lời à Hôm trước tôi chưa trả lời này
muốn thực tập từ năm2 đại học thì phải
chuẩn bị kiến thức gì
ạ năm HA đại học thì em không nên đi
thực tập thì mấy Nói chung là nếu mà
chưa học kiến thức chư ngành am c không
nên tập gì mấy em nếu mà Giả sử có kiến
thức chư ngành thì em vẫn nên làm pet
Project cũng chẳng cần phải nên thực tập
đừng có nên thực tập sớm nó chỉ có năm
cuối mới nên đi thực tập Còn trước đấy
thì em nên làm những các thứ thứ chứ Bây
giờ em lao đầu đi thực tập lao đầu đi
phỏng vấn
thì đấy giống như nhiều ông ở đây cũng
gọi là còn dễ bị nản hơn ấy vì người ta
loại bỏ loại mình nhanh mình sẽ dễ bị
nản ấy đừng đừng cần lên
sớm Và thậm chí là học ở trên trường cho
nó tốt cho nó kiểu hiểu rõ được bản chất
gì ạ Cái hôm trước tôi hỏi tôi trả lời
này mấy ông tra Google có nhiều thư viện
Pit các thứ thứ đấy lắm không chỉ cần
tra đúng ngôn ngữ nữa được ok Ờ rồi nhà
thầy chuẩn bị Tết đến đâu rồi Rất xin
lỗi là thế Xin lỗi là tôi không
hề kiểu nha Thứ nhất là tôi rất là thích
Tết nhưng là tôi a không không giỏi thấy
mạnh của tôi không phải việc nhà nên
thành ra là và mẹ tôi cũng cần giờ cũng
ít giao việc nhà tôi cho tôi làm hay tin
tưởng cho tôi làm nên thành ra tôi không
biết gì mấy cái đấy cả Nhưng mà tôi thấy
là mẹ cũng một mình làm tương đối nhiều
gần hết
lớn Trường Thành rồi Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
sẽ kiểu dạng là phải bắt tay vào làm các
thứ thô Mình phải sống có trách nhiệm
hơn các thứ
thứ Làm sao để gộp code của nhiều ngôn
ngữ vào với nhau vậy thầy không Thực ra
thường là chẳng có ai khái niệm là gộp
code của nhiều ngôn ngữ vào một file hay
cái gì gì đó đâu mà là mình sẽ gọi
gọi gọi qua nhau qua api đấy api bản
chất là nó là kiểu
mình trao đổi dữ liệu các thử thử qua
nhiều ngôn ngữ khác nhau mình xử lý mình
xử lý dữ liệu bằng ngôn ngữ này xong
mình sẽ trả kết quả cho một ngôn ngữ
khác thì ngôn ngữ khác có thể xử lý tiếp
hoặc là in ra màn hình hay gì gì đó ví
dụ Giả sử là với với a Facebook g là một
điển hình hoặc là cái hồi trước ở công
nghệ ở công ty cũ rồi một điển hình lúc
đầu là làm hết bằng pp xong rồi bởi vì
pp nó chạy bị chậm quá nên về sau là sử
dụng Java để mà xử lý cái dữ liệu sau đó
thì trả về kết quả cho pp V pp hiển thị
ra đấy là một
cách đúng rồi đúng rồi anh nào công ty
nào vậy Cái này các bạn xem ở trên
Facebook nhé Nếu không thắc mắc gì nữa
thì tạm kết thúc buổi hôm nay có gì mấy
ông nhắn tin trên discord nhá Ok chào mế